so I get a lot of questions about
why are these Stones so dirty this is
not dirt these are living organisms
these are plants the more polished the
stone the less surface area there is for
the biological organisms to adhere to
the stone and so the reason why we use
this quaternary ammonium compound is
this kills them so these things are
natural in nature you're going to find
in the South especially it's not just
growing on rooftops it's also growing on
our headstones
my name is Trey Zipperer I'm the founder
of by Memorial Day a non-profit
organization dedicated to the cleaning
of all veteran headstones by Memorial
Day in perpetuity
[Music]
so this is a ground level grave marker
issued by the federal government via the
national cemetery Administration it's a
white marble material Natural Stone he
was a Gunner's mate GM third class U.S
Navy I don't think it's respectful to
have a veterans headstone dirty in the
least and so we're going to clean this
headstone of this American hero who gave
his all who sacrificed unimaginable
Horrors for three and a half years as a
prisoner of war the first thing I like
to do is I use a a desk broom to get all
of the sand and debris off of the stone
so we take our water squirt bottle I
like the one with a little bit bigger
base on it I give it a coating of water
because again these these stones are
porous so it's going to soak in this
clean water which is not going to get
down in any chemical down inside the
stone
we use a cleaning agent that contains an
active ingredient known as a quaternary
ammonium compound and it is known and
respected throughout a historic
preservationist as the safest most
effective way to clean natural stones
this brush is made with bristles from
Tampico so the Tampico from the agave
plant is a natural bristle that won't
harm the Natural Stone and then I want
to give it a good coating of the D2
biological solution which is going to go
to work on this Stone very quickly
you're going to see this Stone starting
to turn a bit of an orange color
and then it's going to continue working
on the stone for the next few weeks and
that stone will become brighter and
whiter and wider and you have to clean
them about every two to three years this
does a wonderful job of getting all the
growth killed on the stone
the next step is to let that soak for
about 10 minutes
when I'm looking at a headstone in a
cemetery I want that stone to be
impeccably clean it doesn't matter if
it's almost clean it needs to be clean I
think the reason why some veteran
headstones become more soiled or more
covered in biological growth is because
of the polishing of the stone the more
polished the stone the less surface area
there is for the biological organisms to
adhere to the stone and after about 10
minutes it's not that hard to get the
material off the stone with a soft
bristle natural bristle brush
foreign
then you can get into the etchings with
a toothbrush to get into the real nooks
and crannies of things sometimes
and the final step of honoring a veteran
of our past is to place an American flag
at their grave this is known as a grave
flag this particular grave has already
had an American Legion flag holder
placed at the grave and there's a spot
in the back of them for the flag stick
to just stick right down into it
my vision of by Memorial Day is this one
day in the near future we'll have a
volunteer assigned to every Veteran's
grave in America no matter where that
veteran is buried no matter what
cemetery they're in
so to tell you a little bit about why
this happens these are living organisms
these are plants growing on the stone
whether they're algae or lichens or mold
mildew and so the reason why we use this
quaternary ammonium compound is this
kills them so these things are natural
in nature you're going to find in the
South especially we have this black mold
on all of our our concrete tile roofs
and it's not just growing on rooftops
it's also growing on are headstones
I think it's important that we don't
lose the stories of our veteran Heroes
of the past because they truly are
forgotten their stories are are
disappearing because when they pass away
and the people who knew them pass away
their stories are pretty much gone
forever
so now we're going to start on the
etchings I start with the cross at the
top and work my way down just each
letter
these are etched into the marble
as compared to the early veteran
headstones were bat known as bass relief
where the letters were basically
sticking out they removed the material
around the letters so the letters became
kind of like three-dimensional the
material that grows inside these Stones
it's a combination of things that fixed
in there and also there's little Ledges
so to speak where when the wind blows
the pollen Falls all different types of
things will just get wedged and just
build up in these etchings
assistant
grave Flags measure eight inches by 12
inches but I would rather have a flag
than no flag so if you can't find an 8
by 12 that doesn't mean you can't place
a flag at the grave the person at a
Podium speaking for example the American
flag is to their right so in this case
we have a headstone of American veterans
so as the veterans looking at you the
flag needs to be to his or her right you
want to get as close to the stone as you
can without marring the stone with your
Mallet because when the weed eaters and
other types of Maintenance equipment
comes through you don't want them
hitting your flag holder
the way that I researched the veterans
buried beneath the veteran headstones
that I clean is by using the internet
first and I go to certain sources that I
know contain content such as
findagrave.com there's a several
different websites like that and by
looking into those different databases
and different family trees on
ancestry.com you can start to put
together the story of a veteran and
every now and then you just get
something that's amazing and insightful
that you didn't anticipate
this is a application for headstone or
marker for a deceased American Veteran
the family members would have to
complete this application in order to
choose what style a veteran headstone
that they wanted for their loved one and
this particular application is for
Robert S Lewis prepared by his father
and this is where the story of his
sacrifice became apparent
this man was a sergeant Sergeant shadman
was a top turret Gunner fire in the
cockpit could not see if he got out I
saw Sergeant shadman reaching for a
parachute I do not believe he could have
gotten out alive because the plane broke
apart where he was last seen when they
were attacked they were flying at 24 000
feet Sergeant shadman was up in the top
turret he was a Gunner and he was trying
to get out of that top tour as the plane
was tumbling to the ground his death
state says September 12 1944 but there's
evidence to suggest that he did in fact
get out of that aircraft and he did
reach the ground alive because there's a
hospital admission record of him in
September 1944. we don't know what day
that he died but his mother applied for
his veteran headstone with a death date
of September 23rd
in your local cemeteries there are Local
Heroes whose graves are in really bad
condition and it's pretty sad that a man
or a woman gives their life for our
country and then they're forgotten in
the cemetery and their headstone can't
even be read because there's so much
biological filth on it there are people
in America who care about veterans
Graves they just don't know what's
happening out here so I want to bring
this story to them so that they know
that in your local cemeteries there are
Local Heroes whose graves are in really
bad condition so if this is something
that speaks to your heart I encourage
you to get out your local Cemetery see
for yourself if there's veteran
headstones in need of cleaning in your
local area and take the initiative to do
something about it
foreign